i'm with the schwartz and trooper amish
which are the most conservative of the
amish you have no clue what's going on
this last year in the united states we
don't have canoes or television or
anything we don't even have phones they
were cool with the camera as long as i
wasn't showing them that's unbelievable
two hundred fifty dollars for red and
harrison
that's our light your birthday present
dragon chair every day what do you guys
talk about made by the finest pack
crafts lady in the world
do you get around in the snow with the
horses and characters i don't want to go
to be honest
all right guys here's the story when
shooting videos in different subcultures
there's usually a wall you hit the more
conservative you go
you know say with the amish or the
hasidic jews the less likely you can
bring a camera into that space so i've
hit that wall here i'm with the schwartz
and trooper
amish which are the most conservative of
the amish
yesterday i was at a house
and actually looking for a hat i have a
hat right now
this is a dan amish hat but it's it's
sort of poking on my
my forehead it's a little tight so i
decided to have a custom
made hat made
and there's this schwarzen trooper
family
through a contact that you know said we
can we can do it so we went to their
home
the the woman measured my head
uh very very nice woman but i couldn't
you know i can't bring a camera in these
environments i'm gonna get the hat and
uh
maybe i'll have a story for you
so the schwartz and troopers have no
electricity that's the traditionally
minded amish so when you people think of
amish from the outside world
they usually are thinking of shorts and
troopers toilet outside i think they
have toilet outside no electricity
no phones
large large farm
and like i said guys i would love to
bring the camera in here their house is
is really cool inside everything is
made of hardwood
a lot of varnish on everything all the
furniture is handmade
and i'm gonna have to bring the camera
down out of respect got a guard dog here
i didn't think i'd be able to film the
schwartz and troopers but i asked the
young couple if i could and surprisingly
they agreed but under one condition i
couldn't show them
so you made all these hats yeah yeah
yeah
sports and trooper hat
made by the finest
hat crafts lady in the world
to say
probably
hey it's the only hat that tip fit me in
holmes county i've tried on the 50 of
them your full-time job is making ads
mostly yeah
maybe in the summer she also does
some other zooing
but she has time you know like clothes
pants and shirts and all that stuff okay
yeah i like in the shorts and trooper
homes that all the hardwood you make all
the furniture right yeah we made all the
furniture so you're from i'm from
florida right yeah that's where i lived
my wife and i moved from california to
florida oh i see yeah yeah
it is very warm there right now oh it's
so hot
yeah it was so beautiful today i like
this weather are you husband wife yeah
yeah yeah we're 25 and six so yeah okay
do your parents live here too
uh no that's my brother your brother
okay okay why are you moving
it spoke to her parents she comes from
up there uh your parents miss you yeah
on the farm
they want you back huh
you need help so yeah oh you're taking
over their farm yeah so that's how it
works right so you you grow up just they
just turn it over to us you know yeah
that's great i love how your gardens
everything you grow yourself
well i like i like to grow we like to
grow ourselves yeah it's our meat we
have our own meat so you got a classic
stove here
and
you made this this furniture piece my
wife
okay can i open yeah
it's got it's really um
well varnished you guys sand this a lot
and
if you uh
too yeah sure let's check it out yeah
i'm keeping you off camera though okay
yeah okay so just saying no you don't
mind no okay now dude
not if you're completely off yeah right
so you got all your china in there
you got great old hardwood floors
that's a family clock yeah
13 brothers and sisters well yeah we i
have uh
10 brothers and three sisters
and she's got
in there too can i show yeah that's cool
all right because i'm making sure not to
get you in it
yeah it's
this is very nice yeah
okay so you have a
desk to write yeah that's true yes
classic chair
wood stove and the bureau
gas lamps yeah so at night this is what
uh
kerosene lamps yeah so at night this is
what you're using that's our light yep
okay
and what is it this is a sewing kit yeah
machine yeah this was my birthday
present right here
your birthday present
drugging chair
your wife bought it for you or she had
it for you no if you did not make it she
didn't make it okay she bought it for
you yeah this is your birthday this year
yeah
everything's so solid here yeah
you know in the outside world a lot of
the times the wood is hollow they're
just to make it cheaper yeah
you know i've noticed in this world that
everything is
we go with harvard it's all hardwood huh
yeah
we call it a
lodge
instead of a couch yeah so when you're
together when an english man like me
meaning an outsider comes in you speak
english obviously but when you're
together you're speaking pennsylvania
and dutch all the time right yeah we do
so you don't speak english much during
the day you know we do
in
you know here and there we get an
english word some of the words are in
english actually
that you use in pennsylvania
what's an example like now is it
that's pretty much
same now now yeah now now it's not yeah
no some words are almost english you
know okay yeah how do i say uh
let me think of something i love the
hats
yeah
yeah yeah yeah doctor hood yeah i
collect the food i is yaw right now
okay alice claw you understand that what
alice claw
that's german high german it means it's
okay it's cool oh i was claw yeah
yeah yeah
it's okay if i yeah you're sure yeah
just come in okay
how many um
how many kids do you guys want to have
well it all depends i mean we we have
marriott
five years almost five years and we
don't have here yet so okay okay gotcha
we got you we don't we didn't trust
it's all up to everything's up to god
right yeah i guess so yeah
i don't have any kids either i've been
married one year definitely late to the
party yeah but uh we've been together
four years i don't know yeah
well we were three years
before we married yeah that's
unbelievable 250 dollars for rent here
yeah it's two levels how many rooms
uh we've got upstairs are two
two big rooms okay and then
down here and then
no utilities no
water water you have on property yeah
there's a well out here out here yeah
okay electricity not not happening the
gas i guess for the lambs yeah well
that's kerosene and gas
is for the washing machine
that's all the gas we use is machine
motors
okay so yeah we don't have any gas piped
in we all get the just a fueling station
and kerosene is
we get our tubes or the legs so that's
normal like two 250 dollar rent that's
yeah that's kind of so this is a family
and they're just renting out part of
their home yeah which is a it's like
it's like a separate home yeah this is a
different house so we got a bigger house
over there so i don't want to go to be
honest it's like
it's been very relaxing here yeah
yeah because
look everyone's got their problems
doesn't matter where in the world
everyone's got problems yeah
but you guys
you guys don't have some of the problems
of the outside world right yeah you
don't have any crime here right i mean
very little right it doesn't exist yeah
you're not you don't watch the news or
anything we don't watch we don't have
anything like that you're completely
removed yeah
we don't we don't have
news or television or anything we don't
even have phones or anything like that
so you're just completely in your own
world you got your family
you got a family you got your land yep
wow
so you have no clue what's going on this
last year in the in the united states
not really
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah we do i mean i about to spend maybe
everything we found oh you know about
the pandemic yeah because because that's
everywhere but um but as far as like the
news what's going on in u.s cities or
what's going on with politics or i don't
know anything about that so yeah
all right i'm gonna learn from you guys
wow
that's great unfortunately my camera
battery died without me knowing and i
missed some golden content they told me
they didn't know who the president was
they were also very fascinated about
airplanes and asked me what flying
through the clouds was like and how it
felt to be like a bird
every day what do you guys talk about
you talk about just
the nature the seasons
that's what we were doing today and
yeah
just simple
yeah i guess it's
yeah we don't even we don't recognize it
you know we don't write but it's simple
to us it's trusted
probably like you have it it's common
but you're just used to what you're used
to that's how life is yeah
like you are used to what you're used to
right now it's nice summer you know and
birds are chirping and everything and
like
fall begins suddenly start
change color
yeah then winter i like snow yeah
and well then we're all always ready for
spring you know it's yeah i like i like
how do you get around in the snow with
the horses and carriages
well on waves we can get around better
than you can with your vehicle okay
how's that oh because the wheels go
right through yes it's and the hardest
they play
i mean the shorts and troopers have
steel wheels and the old order have
steel wheels
the
yeah
yeah well we are all the order that's
why you're considered older
yeah you're not sports and troopers
where's where's schwarzenegger but that
is old order yeah
all the articles it's so confusing yeah
there's so much murder is from
swarthmore to tobe or whatever you know
it's our dan dan are they old order
they're all over yeah
but
in schwartz and trooper old order yeah
and then new order new order that's new
beachy yeah
ichi amish or new order i'm not quite
sure
what that even is i'm there they're
almost like mennonites yeah i guess yeah
that's probably why
do they drive the eagle
they drive yeah yeah so that's probably
what we call new order right yes i think
that's a new order probably okay yeah
i'm not but that might be jam not quite
shorty you know what it is so yeah i
like your hats the best
yes one here
yeah
well i like that i mean you guys have
the best hat you have the best style
hats i gotta say
yeah that's it that's sometimes a little
challenge to make a hat like that is
this the biggest size you've ever done
the biggest size i've ever made out of
how many
probably 601 i'm gonna picture
it was fun to make
for the shape of my head yeah because
it's more like an egg it's not not wrong
it's it's not bad if you got the right
stretcher
it's all about the stretcher yeah we use
a stretcher we have to you know to shave
it but what time do you go to bed
i like to until 8 30 but not always 8 30
to 9 00 maybe 9 30.
and then what time are you
3 30 3 30 in the morning yeah
off to work
i stand up and go out and get my horse
ready you know and
i go forward
what time does your work start
uh 5 30. okay okay two hours after i get
up on at work
how long is your commute how long do you
have to go uh
half an hour okay i could drive like it
was hard from buggy you know so you know
yeah
so we just did a
custom job because i have no hair yeah
we put a little padding at the top
oh yeah
that that's the fit
and it feels good
it feels good it fits good
at least yeah thank you so much you guys
yeah if you just don't get anybody
through the picture you know no people
no people then we're good okay
thank you so much yeah best of luck
thank you best of luck with everything
god bless
god bless thank you and i hope to see
you both once again i hope one day yeah
i like you we might be god willing yeah
we might be farming everybody okay if
you can't find
us yeah
sure
thank you so much
and it's again it's okay if i just take
a
of the front of the house
okay
wow what a what an experience
what a cool couple
well guys one of those experiences in
life that
you can't put into words you can't put
into
can't measure with money
such
such nice people
i'm sort of like in awe at the moment to
be honest and this is what i love about
the united states
it's everything it's so
mixed up and diverse
and the deeper you go down the rabbit
hole like i've been doing this a lot
this last year
uh it's just it keeps expanding
and true honor to be let into that
experience
that's about as close as i'm going to
get to the schwartz and troopers and at
least with you that's a little insight a
little
inroads to a world you probably have
never experienced
all right guys until the next one
what's going on here dennis oh this is
interesting wow in amish country you
have one room school houses or how does
this work first grader could be sitting
here and the sixth grader could be
sitting up there they do know some
lebron james that name pops up it comes
in the paper
that's a natural gas light no smoke
these are pretty aggressive
teeter-totters they are
no american flag we're completely free
from government cute little outhouse so
what's different about the amish
curriculum are you familiar with the us
curriculum we start the day off in the
morning with the lord's prayer kids want
to give them phones devices
getting relationship advice out here too
my children coming after me
where do i want them to be
in 30 years
[Music]